I'm always adjusting my mic I'm getting
ready for this because I do this
horrible job of messing the audio for
hot guys
happy Thursday I'm Eric that's Joey
obviously he says it in our names there
and it turns out we got to play Mario
vs. Capcom wins marvel I guess now we
can only play certain modes
I believe it's training tutorial and vs.
right yeah so we can go through some of
the training for people so that they can
kind of see what that looks like I don't
even know it did you mess with this pit
you think that's a good spot oh that's
yeah that's fine there's always stuff at
the bottom we can always get rid of us
too at some point but I'll let Joey show
you something on the tutorial before he
straight whoops my ass inverses because
we can't do the mission mode right okay
you I don't know you tell me
you know the embargoes better than I do
I will look that up in the meantime okay
but I have not played any marvel
what's up Marco uh-huh well that's not
you I played marvel to Marvel 3 you know
x-men Street Fighter but I've not played
any infinite whereas Joey has gone to a
couple events and has been lapping it up
yesterday going through tutorial
missions so if I get some I get some if
I can't kill even one of his guys it's a
moral victory in my opinion but I'd
rather him swag on me with with combos
anyways
although so much about swagging quite
yet so I saw some swag like not I'm not
saying like huge like you know 30 40 50
hit combos but you definitely have some
you definitely have some tech guys I saw
it I saw is it looks like versus mode
training yeah that was my bought my bad
Josh I forgot to change the switch title
because I'm novice alright so a is
training at vs there yeah yes yes I
thought so told me that originally
who are your who are your main what has
been your main kind of go to so far like
one okay so in in Marvel 3 I played
along Dante and like Dante just like
playing him again you have to if you put
if you pick a character that was like
originally in three you're gonna have
like a rewire your brain in order to
they don't work the same way but your
your fingers do automatically want to go
to like a certain button like you think
you realize does something completely
different so I gotta like really gear
everything no you got the muscle memory
down yeah so IV got it it's something
it's always good to like pick someone
who's like maybe go war champion at all
I would lose in first round of pool
fools battle pants I will check the game
swatch at - that's right so hey guys
just so you know we stream every day at
11:00 a.m. we're even on periscope today
hello to the folks on periscope and yeah
we will try to answer as many questions
as we can I will relay those over to
Joey and yeah that's how we're having
kind of go about it saying we appreciate
you guys I'll pick your characters for
the fir-tree mode so for you just in
case you want to jump in I will take
Captain America green one of gray and
[Music]
Arthur Arthur really yeah xr0 know
Arthur I did not play that scumbag pizza
cutting zero that was Julio Peck time I
need Wesker man I only know Wesker got
you got a Hawkeye who's like you just
stole his outfit yeah that's true so
also one of the new things in this game
if you guys didn't know already is there
are Infinity stones obviously that have
different kind of interactions with an
abilities pretty much and then also like
you can like trigger the like gem when
you hit like a higher level yeah to like
pull you into like almost a different
reality or whatever different reality
and they all do like these huge
game-changing things that's kind of like
the x-factor in this yeah right but it's
it's more long lines of the original
Marvel superheroes
remember that they also had gyms oh
that's right but it would look different
though yeah they were just like
increased speed reader damage filled
meter a little bit but like the ones
that they have in the game now are just
so pretty crazy oh so you want to get
rekt by cat huh
and also the other kind of difference in
this game is like they got the tagging
now right would ya kind of like that
cross ii you just tagged however many
times you want combo oh use my gym
author
oh yeah he's still got it yep here we
throw something at me again
I come with throw him back the firebomb
okay so it's a back light punch with a
forcible back back back hard yeah good
cheese today I forget can they assist or
no who here your partner don't so you
have to call them in and then as you're
doing explain ground to air combos
please says kungfu Jesse alright show me
some of that
so there's your typical combo right here
Walter
but some there are some attacks that
when you hit them down it creates like a
bigger bounce so
oh it's Lex you're just like that it's
just like the typical like ground slam
but if you do like it's helm breaker at
the top you can realize and I heard you
can only realize like once right once
pretty rare yeah so like when you when
you switch over they'll get another one
up right here
Ghost Rider oh well the cool thing about
Ghost Rider I saw this yesterday do your
gods bracelet was activated like I
missed it too
try it again okay all right you go first
right or me oh wow it's so far okay
maybe I Harbor though yeah
like it has like infinite armor
yeah I'm gonna gave one yeah not even
air you already oh look at the Hat day
one mashing let's go
well one of the other things I say they
added was that if you just hit the light
punch over and over it'll do like just
look at that one crane cab yeah you'll
do like it basically just like a regular
combo like Oh like that 1 2 3 4 but like
okay so just but less damage right left
and it's what's damaged yeah and you
can't really do much after that okay I
like this time jump if you get that you
get those mix-ups of the time so you
could do that throw the bottle throw
that bottle
oh you're sore go see with my flame
bottle
like so do you feel like God gave as
good as he wasn't through he's I feel
like he has a potential to be I think
he's just gonna be very very very
different because like a lot of his
moves like for example to show you one
so like uh far it is a this corset
before a hard punch does crystal and
like in the first game if you press it
again you'll get this guy but then you
can press it apart much a third time
since there's only four buttons now and
then frozen a diet can't break out of
that faster so it has like some of the
old moves have different properties now
you can follow it up afterwards teleport
is no longer down downs like Corsica
fact like buns
no I got is like boomerang shoe that
doesn't work anymore
home breaker or guns after that you
can't huh that jumping hard kick it's so
different oh yeah here we go
I was watching pressing button oh it's
like it's another dumb unyielding
justice unyielding just fine although
final justice when did this come out
September 19 this is your trigger it's
also oh they both come out oh how do I
block this so cheater
oh look at that that's so cheap or I put
myself in the box Space Jam is pretty
funny too because they put you in the
box
oh the spacesuit yeah that one's pretty
good but like the soul so I feel like is
the one that's gonna change a lot of
people's opinions about the game
oh yeah come on that's also good combos
like a pickled caper I've been messing
around with it but he was doing like
four different shields in one combo I'm
sorry I reap it you up yeah all right so
what else you got for me
god of God of lamb says the rosters
lacking I don't know that's a lot of
decent amount of cash 30 is is a lot
less than what like Marvel - Marvel 3
started out with definitely and then yo
you'll see like I even saw today like
something like some people speculating
Gil's gonna be in the Gil and venom yeah
cuz the venom like voice lines came out
or something well really I hear the
voice lines
yeah damn dingo that was kind of weird
like I was maybe it's like we're you it
doesn't matter where you do the Endor to
get the bounce because you saw me easily
scoop you that one time back up but then
in the corner when I kept doing it I was
doing this it depends although the move
of the door that you use to end it like
when you win it like a slammed you down
okay will be OTG capable others not
still need a lot more lab working his
firebrand in his honor
no one likes [ __ ] ha like my characters
aren't even in this game taskmaster wet
Wesker those those the basis of my team
I'll give you all right gimme Wesker
that's West Karen all give me someone
definitely I guess yeah I don't know how
good though I wanted to meet me man
Demetri that's the ryu of Darkstalkers
he is literally the ryu of turf war they
could have put in a the abominable
snowman dude because the I would rather
have so many other people than the
frosty guy forget his name
like there was like B sha Wan write that
words that guy is that the name of door
closes there's the samurai guy which i
think is be shim on there was like the
like Riku there's something that there's
a frog guy they had a nikeyra so I can't
say that one me tree was the guy with
the little kid that liked you for saying
the gill leaf was fake I mean I kind of
want to go back and like look at all the
reddit posts that people have made about
like so called the leaks and see how
accurate they were
oh that's so dirty nice little take that
three hits but Mega Man has a bunch of
like projectiles stove Oh what the hell
is that I was a little try and do this
oh dude I like that though
call back to Mega Man X ring there's no
way to turn off California boys that
link it should get in here pull him in
so spacejam pulls you in right and then
the the thingy put Unabomber
check out some pretty cool stuff we
gotta pick up dead I know yang please -
pelipper this way my kissa also play
some of the tradition then oh look at
that
oh that's my boy yeah that's like that
and I held it and that's me he basically
doesn't need to fly this
sorry I'm day one guys I'm dating right
now so you got Megaman if you do like a
regular mustard you can follow it up by
pressing Oh
[Music]
that's not what you want to do but then
dingos asking dudes wavedashing work it
does in like you can still do it but
it's not like look at me doing down pat
like I've heard them say that it's not
as it's like oh yeah it's before like
it's not as necessary this is what
you're supposed to do but it was a combo
Oh
there you go right now press buttons
baby it's that easy though oh oh here's
the slide too
does he still have poison arrow oh you
can shoot out yeah hi you gonna have the
Goblin uh-huh not yet I'm with Nick
movie hey you know Dennis Kinnear dad oh
let's play destiny Tuesday I tell you
one sorry I needed a break I want to see
some of that new hot camera tech we've
been camera Oh Frank I think talking
about oh yeah we're gonna get to him he
loves Frankie you played Frankie in
three
you mix me up there so if you do what
liquor circleback like bunch does that
other thing and then trapped into that
Bobby right yeah and so like you kid
night link that though you can actually
okichi off that knock down
so really yeah do crouching like kick
afterwards okay right away
yeah you can follow that up oh that's
weird they didn't count as a combo
okay it could just be me and it could be
my character but does it feel slower
than three feel slower yeah
or about the same I think it feels about
the same I think it's just like
familiarity like what our character
can't even do this was I think people
said the same thing about five five five
yeah it feels yeah but they're like once
people how they basically moves in the
game the each character still have like
two supers that's Matabele three yeah so
um I have it's like for Superboy
Oh see just one tool I got using a short
there yeah so you could just go like
down hard punch again but some of them a
little bit different I was like so if
you see like Mega Man's I'm not sure
yeah I can't uppercut afterwards not as
high of a bounce I guess but he has like
other moves that will do that like this
one there's like 12 opportunities to
stuff
maybe our family's is not the best oh
that hit through the grab what what is
this how do I activate do put a Mitch
box baby it's like it's so blocked but
like and you basically create the corner
wherever you want all right I like this
hello Korean I like what's going on here
cuz I didn't want to bring it up myself
sonic X Ethan bringing up TVs Dragonball
Fighters and that beta is actually this
weekend yeah surprisingly so out of
since we I have played both I have
played maybe like I don't know he was
just like a timing thing yeah but
obviously that that's like that Dragon
Ball that's coming out soon as more
almost in the vein of like a Marvel game
yeah right where's like it really is
like every time they looked at Marvel
Tampax yeah it's got so many things
right it's in the same vein that I don't
know what it is I don't know it
shouldn't be like that where I have to
pick one over the other you should pick
Frank I don't know nothing about Frank's
mine we haven't showed it
so would you try during a bit sonic so I
know that's my personal preference you
played more both now yeah I know you're
a big Marvel guy though so you'll
probably still play both but I think um
I guess here this game has like a lot of
potential like right now I know there's
like memes everywhere just people
complaining about like the way like the
game looked originally and like some
comments about like from the developers
and everything but like once you sit
down and like start experimenting with
what you can even do in the game like
it's it's so open
all right I want you do some combos I'm
gonna move us to bottom middle one milk
almost like as to not take up so much
real estate
actually that might still take out space
near Guerra productions asking is Frank
really that different in from Marvel vs.
Capcom 3 he's he's basically like the
same idea is that like you know you want
to be able to take pictures and level up
your camera but yeah he does have a few
new ways to do that yeah I was like one
whew that's tripod which he can set down
and then you can continue the combo you
don't need to wait for like to snap the
camera it will do it automatically and
then his new level 3 will actually level
you up to level 5 automatically Wow
coolest thing is he's still hampered in
the same way he was in level 3 where you
kind of like you're like whack Frank
West versus like beefed up Frank West
like is that an issue or do you feel
like it's pretty like better now
Frankie zombie cruise oh that's faster
than the older OH
it's personal back partner now that was
picture or this was back to something
maybe hard kick hard kick was this
strike down down on our country there we
go
take it can you hit that put down you
yeah figures
do you guys watch Maximilian - yes okay
come with yeah I watch the dude
what I was tucking there so we got
Dormammu here which if you haven't seen
Filipino champs combo with them it's
that just that alone will give you an
idea I'm glad to see that he's gonna
have the power but the power yeah so
like every time actually he changed that
as well so you can do grab one charge it
up but he'll also do it after every be
really you can still create space while
powering up okay then he's got a new
blue power pulls you in I think
oh that should work why doesn't that
work Joey
which one like why doesn't okay like I
should be like in my head logically I
should be able to do that and recycle so
I think he's a the one that can bounce
is his knee drop so if you do down hard
lunch in the air like as a finisher
then you are again surely right I think
you can reload after that woman
oh he could you both okay apparently
that word all right now show the people
some real combos okay sonic actually
Ethan saying Jetta door mama there's a
decent combo
mark o/s Amy morri you fighter
enthusiastic servers always said also
damn thing go saying glad to see more
money better proper fighting endo
seriously yeah it was interesting to see
just how excited people were during the
Microsoft conference like it was like
one of the loudest moments is when
Dragon Ball that's gone cuz they were
like they did everyone has heard about
it from like that police that time but
no one had actually seen it oh yeah see
that that ground balanced way do you
think it's just yeah there you go
so how come it doesn't say level of
where am I yeah it needs to be like five
hits or 10 hits first oh I get to level
two Stephanie would like you know combo
or or against set up the tripod
yeah boy if he doesn't have to charge
any more it's just hard to the 4-step
ruining my camera Oh
are we stupid oh my god is Kay Blue
River
so Ultron is like people are really
liking him from what I hear he's like
he's fast you can try a lot of like
pretty quick beam attacks and like that
one of these moves is a grab which like
can hold on to him for a while maybe
forcible forward kicks get that one and
so if you do tag right when you do that
you can like see like a setup
no that should've worked oh you know why
is it the long one you did a long one
yeah that one takes longer Oh does okay
so yeah it's too camera shot yeah
he has jab yes Pierre almost sold
problem I don't know why I leveled up
they're probably just like he got to
that that's essential okay so now do I
have shopping carts now of course it for
kicks
oh you're gonna bounce off there what
it's a wall down after you can do
something about getting something sorry
even Meyer is saying listen to Spencer
when you select them it's hilarious
okay
tgd boy good good
grab all the paint that's pretty good
actually
oh that was took the late alright thanks
Mike I like it
okay
no I didn't you come out break you got
maybe do it like right before I was just
spamming it right before thing
so smitten exes hilarious how Frank
style translates into the game he's like
the perfect Marvel character it's just
like tagging stuff I gotta remember you
know me I always like old bread and
butter yeah it's like really hard for me
it does work in some respect here it
gives you a cleaner like it just keeps
refilling
[Music]
yeah
Oh
stopping cardem oh my it's going on oh
the play what'll the flame puddle oh my
god that's so cheap oh that's a really
big bounce
oh they compete
oh you're staggered yeah so like if you
do it once when they get back up they'll
be dizzy and so you get a full combo off
of that oh you can't
oh and it'll work
can you come back right away no dude
dude like a couple seconds oh you so so
that seems kind of hazy that's the one
that people I think we're waiting for
when they show that your character after
they die stays on the screen
people were just speculating like okay
that has to mean something
educators yeah any dips and frames/s
Marco I don't think so no yeah there's a
command grab thank you what is happening
is a good question max on let's see max
andris Bell eval VCO well-versed capital
infinite will be good game because to
the roster characters are Captain Marvel
and all chunk I've heard MCU characters
played by brie Larson and James Spader
Rebecca James Spader I his voice answers
your boy voice get this party started
let's indeed let's do some let's see
Morgan I think okay give me Strider
Captain Marvel Marvel marvel you
tomorrow
I heard she has like a Coolio was
telling me she could like like she could
scoop up off of her
yeah she's got some pretty good like
babies yeah so I need B&Bs I need solid
B and B's and highlight that's my my
go-to and Marvel have you tried Jedi yet
says Magic Man yeah we did a little bit
but from my perspective which is not
very good cuz it's day one for me but
Joey's got combo so if you guys want to
see some some at least less than seven
hit combos you're gonna want to tell
Joey to play that character or I'll tell
Joey to play I tried the the mission
mode for him he that's the one where I
learned that he can do that follow up
after that guy grab makes sense yeah
that's Spencer voice though let's get
this party started
why am I in the corner training make
sure you mood all right how you liking
Spencer in this version now that you
know you played him in three Oh what
okay he has like four different angles
for his
bionic arm
oh okay that was really part of her grab
all that let's get it low there or try
to keep doing yeah they can get him bird
- after that shit's August old for
horizonte' what I thought it was cuz
everything you got down down
commands down yeah
that physical Spencer clothes I don't
think they work anymore you think oh no
no you can't fly cancel via the cotton
villa the fireballs anyway
but he cost me up during lessons when I
think my Fierstein he's asked me if
we're playing on sticks or pad they're
doing one of that pad news although I
feel like patterns had a resurgence
especially like a few yeah definitely if
you play pad that's not anything to be
like ashamed of yeah if you're good on
Pageant this is that you know with like
the arcade culture like that most people
started on like sticks as like she's
fighting for came out like okay you play
just as well on pad six there's no
just train your the old Spencer stuff is
not working get there Bob bird yeah send
my army oh no his arm went through all
my cats let's try to do the up grapple
oh happy birthday something
tomorrow does your level 3 to turn Super
Saiyan so one of her power of supers is
to turn into that how do you do that
things like is it down down punches
maybe oh my god her damage do war dude I
don't know if it what it was doing more
but it just looked like it but just feel
like simple now you know that good well
you know damage she has drill claw well
I was thinking more of like via of
storms thing oh the Lightning yeah
yep easy combo okay then what oh I think
oh you do - Oh easy combo yeah I don't
think he'd still do that those traffic
combos
five virtual time this game that's a way
yes that's now please no oh yeah she has
a new move oh it dreams
would've broke the attaboy okay we don't
activate the same time you can yeah do
you like projectiles oh yeah so like
every every bugger give you like an
elemental attacks
[Applause]
freaking full screen oh this is odg what
is my life anymore end of the word oh I
was
oh the yeah yeah and so the clock
coasting someone and I just know you can
do the was a formation a I think with
the one with the little three cup little
ball on the side
oh yeah and then launch it after that
and then do it yeah that one again oh we
have rolled out or like I think it after
they get knocked down
Oh after the after they get it on the
ground he seems on the girl for a while
I've just habitually just trying to know
okay so they can do yeah again I think
oh dude this yeah yeah I saw clockwork
do that like four times in a row
bingos not very happy about what they
did suspender here's a marvel three main
for him just as two is better to
Sagittarius or something kind of game
and anyway
actually done that yet where you switch
out like mid combo
I never kind of crazy that you can just
keep switching with like although I
guess some of it's telling you that you
can't take like two bars over but we
have two cars here
oh we laughing right now all right you
watch yeah let's do some switching dang
man again thank you guys for tuning in
we are playing more vs. Capcom infinite
in kind of like training mode we're just
messing around as mentioned if you want
to see some combos Joey's your man so
you should pick characters that you want
to see convolutional ask Joey he has
some or like most of the roster me I
like them in the past but Hardin I think
he's he plays very similar he has a lot
of his same table same booth set one
thing though is that his Magnum needs to
be reloaded we hold three bullets for
some reason did you buy that gun from I
was like sure Nova and rocky and I guess
orange like slightly it's like opposite
inverted power I have the power water
you need the time stone yeah we use
thought if Thanos earlier we also use
Hawkeye angler shredder will get some
rival in there frybread
call Israel actually good in an NBC game
now says he's asked fierce deity 101 I
mean this is Ryu he will always be Ryu
hey a lot of people slept on Chun and
then Johnny want evil though so I don't
know if Ryu has the same baby yeah like
with Cho Nene she just needs to find
like the right team the right team you
know
so Ryu and but she was holding her own
though - I feel like you know and she
has an infinite - I think right yeah if
you wanted TAC you can just like hit
them at the top of the screen
the court oh yeah you still got his a
dolphin reload I got to tell you that
I'm reloading his uh with since he's a
different color his uh cleans
oh it's David Miller instead of yellow
and it sounds so Abed there's
crystalline character he looks like what
a character for me just project house Oh
send it back just like DVD oh yeah good
old classic crawl oh he has a shoulder
charge after that you got a plain thirst
oh yeah I think so they still have it it
was like a staple for
I don't have the flame-throwing it'd be
very upset
it used to be kicks lol is it ello and
be well yeah hit a good Chris play
thrower is Ford H hard punch I think
it's a great prize at least be back
gotta extend it with that I need to find
a way
look at that to the mayor you do it's
pretty cool
flamethrower track
[Music]
[Music]
this is powers I can't bring them in
when you're freezing oh maybe because it
counts as a balance right so you
probably can't get another Magnum
afterwards no I wanted him to come back
oh you're crawling come down to your
level
oh no the mayor how do I bring in my guy
so like it brings them in like on the
ground floor whichever way you're facing
Oh try to be the mixer
oh no I'm just a raccoon
[Music]
I kind of like Groot just being in
Rockets moveset
well he doesn't LOGCAP anymore right how
does he know he doesn't it's like
stretching his arm
that's Piper then get barrels out here
oh yeah
looky here
guys are controlling adduced getting
stuff i think like different different
puzzles different days
later we go back to you Gary
sometimes he'll bring all the barrel up
slowly
I'll give you like a health bonus or a
meter bonus Oh like you broke food like
this like chicken big dude go chicken
Oh oh no it's like cambrie Weaver you do
the pipes after that Oh what is that
now punishable
Oh climax so I can't do it when yours is
active oh you can't
[Music]
oh okay is that long reach
yeah I think that's like the new log
trap and you need to go across the
screen late log shot Oh traveling now it
just like occupies you turn your uh
infinity storm now you could do like
custom combos I'll just do like Park
playboys
young skill become energy Gavilan Oh
get in there Groot oh I trying to go
through it's like my Western teleporter
I'm gonna try to time by jakub pest in
the city
dude hey gar is a monster you know we go
for every move does like oh you do know
this level three
ah at some point yeah all right
I think like in a lot of Marvel games
one of the go to level 3 is just like
them running into someone and then
hitting them in the air that's why I
like Phoenix raids
I've got Idol best tend to take you to
court Power Stone Oh alright who haven't
we tried Thor Thor oh you know like yeah
you take who you want give you Ryu and
emesis
I played nemesis in three a little bit
but I wasn't like super good with it no
more is supposed to be pretty fun I was
like I'll just missing out there a
little bit before we started Oh
spider-man forgot about yes by T he's
even in like every Marvel game Oh Cathy
commando I'm yes lords ending I'd love
to have commando back alright
who that blue matching stone you wanna
do Sol No
[Music]
don't you guys know croute was Rockets
log chap see three just disguise a
second one big long shot
nemesis can combo with rocket rocket
rocket hyper you can shoot two minutes I
think like he does she like
in an hyperope of that oh yeah there you
go Oh yep
now yeah maybe in the media the corner
you get the
I'd like spider-man in in this game cuz
like when you just doing the web ball
over and over
oh wow like wild again hip fights will
be owned what's the grab it's kind of
weird see like in three they didn't have
kicks it was just an attack like to give
every character like two kicks now I
think
my team is here - we are only on the I
think I have to do quarter circle
god
fighter fight its Spidey sting holy boy
they're just absorbs it no hits a low
doesn't low jab this is just a short
that's three let's two hits of armor
oh god his [ __ ] is so short still the
range there overhead
[Music]
Oh too early he really needs you to fall
oh so you found like a lot of good like
pressure good like you're pressuring me
so much love that
oh yeah Kimora's like people went when
she was announced I was like I don't
really like the way her character looks
at either like she didn't really like
strike me as an interesting
and then do the Dookie afterwards I
think you just aim it after
okay
oh no happy birthday hello WebKit
spider Canyon aim it down yeah yeah you
can name it down is that did you have to
hold that yeah that's pretty cool
take them out once at the time because
if I don't hit it
it's only pulls it it doesn't push them
away [ __ ] but like if their trend
jumping on you you just pull them out
Oh
oh come on we could do afterwards this
building meters
I'm in a box you can still go but I can
only come alone go search the creek they
can't get out of the box you see in
there put my boot there be able to get
out there some spider I think oh it can
good save
oh right into it see people in the chat
talking about uh I think like one one
guy on Twitter
I saw put it best is basically saying
like the game kind of lacks that the the
contrast of three we're like things
don't really like look at that different
from the backgrounds so it can be hard
to see it sometimes
you just compliment me present I tried
to counter with shoryuken level 3
okay yeah switch out
we gotta get Thor I think and I'm not
sure who else it's got a couple we're
having week going along guys they're
starting to come what to say well that's
why we haven't got there yeah we didn't
pick zero yet
let's go zero in our view yeah we have a
big iron man give me thorns and look at
that actually look at that new chun-li
face you after you pick strange
yeah it looks better like Chavo yeah
give me some doctor swag and who Thor
we're doing the New Avengers movies with
zero yes I hope they put the that blue
the Blue Man Group Doctor Strange in the
new
people like that or toast manic says
that Ironman colors nice night in New
Orleans Saints Brown was it brown it
looks like for beige in a black yeah
it's all about looking good man did you
see was it kept in Marvel's with a
premier skin or whatever they want to
call them yeah I think it was a
pre-order bullets with ps4 zero so do
you remember Doctor Strange and three
much but you do like those Grace's I got
mojo so you like you can like mash the
orbs I mean just like that's put three
instead of doing like three in
my go where my oh they seventh Street
got to hold the Buster like the same
yeah I think they gave Thor like a new
projectile like he can throw his hammer
or something built the mighty spirit
okay when would you ever have time to
pull that off
it's like in-between character death I
guess
[Music]
he has a new super
fear of Okimoto
whiskey pressing buttons oh and a
reality lightning oh there we go
Oh
a lot of good
that's my [ __ ] mind
Oh smart one so I was like
Oh
oh is it account yeah this is a
projectile
how can I didn't stop here but I think
it was like anyone dudes asking about
down on puts are they changed most of
the shoryuken movements into down down I
thought I would actually hate it cuz I
was so used to doing it but like just
practicing with it maybe after like half
an hour or an hour like it becomes
pretty natural like I don't really think
about it anymore really
not
oh come on I try to time it's a clutter
so he goes back got a character
Oh follow up our night way dude
oh you can't call someone in goes doc or
is really solid in this game probably
it's not in my hand like every it's like
hard work will give you that will give
you that flame thing going across try to
reflect it reactionary play
home or scaling
oh that's pretty dirty stuff boomerang
which would meringue into like just like
hitting this one so if I throw that I
don't know how you do it behind that I
don't know it looked like I threw it
behind me at one point and then I was
able to
estranged versus dr. doom only they put
doom in here
power needs it
that's nice
this is air - away amenities super I
don't know
that's one over his head yeah it's not
the blasts anymore
go where am I
I don't know is hoping to juggle you
again I usually do some combos you toss
the audio stone to switch coffee on are
mine doesn't pick people up right mom it
stays out there use it to zone I think
that's what they wanted to do with
Ironman make it more of like a loner
[Music]
so yeah there's no nothing here to like
actually just track help it's always
gonna come back saying like so there's
nothing here to make it like a natural
version card right
unless you want to go in okay let's go
play a real match we're gonna do a
best-of-three Joey
premium okay I feel like I'm gonna get
one round out of three not gonna have it
roll away if you choose Spencer with the
reality stone he'll say Jellystone kinda
won this I kind of want to hear it
alright who's felt good
I think all chimes oh my god the red
there's 90 colors it's a combo easy
customer soul still no oh you would you
would I put your put your money and put
your your salty bets are just right on
the front yeah I don't have my quarter
still in the
yes no perfect
happy birthday
whoa does it always flow down there we
go
no no it's tipping this stuff on the
ground oh yeah scaly though
I thought I would I thought it I thought
I was gonna really smash though he might
have taken it a little easy there but I
feel good I feel pretty good about that
it was not not terrible
alright yeah Jenna Spray sake I wish I
could represent her better but uh
apologies the door mom wingspan yeah
yes we wrote eg eg oh really
I was the year since level 3 for some
reason
once again it's all part of the plan oh
I almost got you damn it the flame
cupcakes too strong
oh now happy birthday oh you guys you
getting your life back huh
[Music]
god
no guys no ice - no the choke the choke
is coming know what I'm doing was a
living really close so I did okay I
didn't realize
okay it was all part of his plan he
brought his other character back to life
Oh - good thing you didn't bet on me I
want that salty runback I want a new
team
we should've been just doing this from
the beginning alright we get we're gonna
we're gonna get engaged as a salty
runback character select yeah I'm gonna
I'm gonna stick with Ultron but I'm
gonna go for freedom I mean are you can
you play we can play by to fire break
[Music]
you want it accident zero don't do it
I'm not proficient enough I mean zero is
pretty good just like she's well maybe
rocket
old buddies Dante Frank who's that
septum or no it's not actually
I always I there's a long time I thought
her son was MODOK she Bay's on the game
just in the background
so you you liked the time stone I just
like having reminds me like CBS CBS 2
having the role yeah you groove so just
for that and custom combos yeah those
are pretty cool as long as your
character has something that can like
move forward a little bit with like a
hard punch
oh I was swagged on you're joking still
kind of doing it
oh no I gave it back to them you can get
past this bike already shield is
stronger than not stronger than the
flight oh my go
ladies always going to fight Hey
[Music]
quickly get in here darn it oh that's
too bad that is dumb Red Ranger ace is
the Gil leak is fake isn't it I don't
know I people pose all these leaks all
the time I mean they just take like what
might be plausible like venom obvious
like monitor like yeah I don't
understand why anyone would ever not
pick soulstone yeah I mean you can't
it's like situational like you need to
have the line die in order for it to
work
yeah I'm just saying like as like a new
coming right I mean like it doesn't give
you any like really amazing like powers
like I'm sewing or anything like your
characters are pretty much still the
same
no the shield
Oh Helen breaker Oh work
x-factor
oh I try to flip through it it was a bad
bad idea
oh he still comes for a third time with
that little three they just I think goes
back and forth
bulgogi combo
I call them the demon hunter though oh
yeah okay as it should be it's good
matches oh do I need a lab it up just
like with any other fighting game you
just gotta hit the lab find out which
characters fit you which stone fits you
thanks Joey
for swagging on me to do bad Beck as my
deck says watch Joey swag on Eric with
sick combos or some sick combos anyways
that was a little taste of Marvel vs.
Capcom infinite that was just like a
tutorial and some verses that game comes
out September 19th
I believe Tuesday Tuesday so if you're
interested in that check that out also
as mentioned earlier don't forget dragon
ball fighters if you got into the beta
that's this weekend Saturday Sunday
check that out if you got that obviously
and don't forget as always we are live
every day at 11 a.m. so come hang out
with us if you haven't subscribed ready
think about doing that so you get
notified for our live streams as well as
all the other cool stuff we make until
tomorrow I believe I'm gonna do this
honored the death of the outsider if I
got that right yep John Luke
so come check that out yes I wish BB
hood with an awesome but until next time
guys from me and Joey we appreciate it
see you guys later I'm good Thursday
smile baby Baba wins my votes now
[Music]
[Music]
you